dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir this work is
about creating an AI that can perform
audio-visual correspondence this means
two really cool tasks one when given a
piece of video and audio it can guess
whether they match each other
[Music]
[Music]
and two it can localize the source of
the sounds heard in the video
[Music]
mmm-hmm and wait because this gets even
better as opposed to previous works here
the entire network is trained from
scratch and is able to perform cross
modal retrieval cross modal retrieval
means that we are able to give it an
input sound and it will be able to find
pictures that would produce similar
sounds or vice-versa
for instance here the input is the sound
of a guitar note the loudspeaker icon in
the corner and it shows us a bunch of
either images or sounds that are similar
marvelous the training is unsupervised
which means that the algorithm is given
a bunch of data and learns without
additional labels or instructions the
architecture and results are compared to
a previous work by the name look listen
and learn that we covered earlier in the
series the link is available in the
video description as you can see both of
them run a convolutional neural network
this is one of my favorite parts about
deep learning the very same algorithm is
able to process and understand signals
of very different kinds video and audio
the old work concatenates this
information and produces a binary yes/no
decision whether it thinks the two
streams match this new work tries to
produce a number that encodes the
distance between the video and the audio
kind of like the distance between two
countries on a map but both video and
audio signals are embedded in the same
map and the output decision always
depends on how small or big this
distance is this distance metric is
quite useful if we have an input video
or audio signal choosing other video and
audio snippets that have a low distance
is one of the important steps that opens
up the door to this magical cross modal
retrieval what a time to be alive some
results are easy to verify others may
spark some debate for instance it is
quite interesting to see that the
algorithm highlights the entirety of the
guitar string as a sound source if you
are curious about this mysterious blue
image here make sure to have a look at
the paper for an explanation now this is
a story that we would like to tell
to as many people as possible everyone
needs to hear about this if you would
like to help us with our quest please
consider supporting us on patreon you
can pick up some cool perks like getting
early access to these videos or deciding
the order of upcoming episodes details
are available in the video description
thanks for watching and for your
generous support now see you next time
[Music]
you